a couple just went viral for bragging
about the dink lifestyle we're dinks
we're going to get asked daily when we
plan on having kids we're dinks of
course we're going to go out to eat
every night after work we're dinks we
don't have to ask our family for
financial help or to watch our kid when
we want to go out we're dinks we're
going to go to Costco and buy all the
snacks in bulk that we want we're dinks
we have disposable income to spend on
whatever we would like and don't have to
spend on a kid we're dings I'm going to
go to Every football game and play 18
holes whenever I want we're dinks we're
going to get asked to every single
family event what we're doing with our
life I'm depressed cuz I just watched
this video I'm very sad about the state
of our culture cuz I just watched that
video I'm frankly not betting on much of
a future for Western Civilization cuz I
just watched that video I'm I'm Michael
I'm Michael this new trend of the I'm
blah blah blah and blah blah blah blah
blah that I've seen go around the
Internet it's absolutely unbearable and
it's especially unbearable when you're
talking about something like the Dinks